a wildly triggered failed former
president Donald Trump even before Ron
DeSantis announced that he was running
for president released an attack ad on
Ron DeSantis calling him a swamp
creature let's take a look at this this
might give us a little bit of a preview
of the sorts of lines of attack that we
may be seeing during what is certainly
going to be an extremely ugly Republican
primary campaign take a look
Trump defeats the
2016. president Trump defeats the
Liberals and heads to Washington to
train the swamp but swap creature Ron
DeSantis is about to start his third
term in Congress and he's already voted
repeatedly to cut Social Security and
Medicare
2017. Trump passes huge tax cuts for
nearly everyone and Ron DeSantis he's
pushing a bill that would swap those tax
cuts for a new 23 national sales tax so
let's just pick pick this families pay
more just to pick I can't fact check
everything here but Trump has been
saying this a lot that Ron DeSantis was
going to put in a 23 sales tax and and
you know uh make everybody pay more the
reality is what DeSantis supported was
part of the fair tax proposal and what
that would have done is put in a 23
national sales tax but get rid of income
taxes pay payroll taxes estate taxes and
gift taxes and the idea was simplify the
tax code and make it more transparent by
lowering taxes for rich people so is it
a lie to say descent is supported a 23
national sales tax it's not a lie but it
was a right-wing proposal to lower taxes
on the rich imagine that you're in the
37 federal tax bracket and then you've
got
uh your Social Security Medicare and so
on and so forth
if you replace all of that stuff if you
get rid of income tax payroll tax estate
tax and gift tax and you just pay twenty
three percent that's a ma on what you
spend that's an insane decline in taxes
on the rich so like is it a lie what
Trump is saying in the ad it's not a lie
but it's extraordinarily deceptive
. Trump is building a wall securing the
Border fighting The Invasion while Ron
DeSantis is voting against funding for
Trump's wall in Washington one was a
leader and one let us down even DeSantis
admitted there are big differences
between him and Trump obviously there is
because I voted contrary to him
so this is going to be such an ugly
primary that it's going to make your
head spin but also a factor will be that
Trump is constantly lying about DeSantis
and if DeSantis decides to acknowledge
that Trump is running right because so
far it's been like just don't even talk
about Trump
is he going to tell the truth about
Trump policy or is he going to have to
lie to draw distinctions that don't
really exist we're going to watch it